[Musik]
schwerlasttransporter die giganten der
straße länger als zwei omnibusse breiter
und schwerer als jeder normale lkw
fahrer steuert die riesen dinger seit 20
jahren
oft ist der wochenlang unterwegs
familienleben fast nur übers telefon
gerade vorbeigefahren
ich hab dich lieb
bevor sich die schau
[Musik]
harvey fährt fast nur nachts das ist
vorschrift in den meisten bundesländern
weil sein gefährt so groß und schwer ist
4 uhr 30
die tour ist noch lange nicht rum und
das härteste kommt erst eben erfährt er
von kollegen über funk dass unmittelbar
vor ihm ein schlimmer unfall passiert
ist
vollsperrung der autobahn feuer die ist
gefährlich nah dran an der unfallstelle
die anspannung ist groß keiner weiß was
da los ist
feuerwehr und notärzte rasen über die
standspuren was ist mit dem fahrer
konnte er rechtzeitig raus und immer
wieder knallt es hardy macht sich ernste
sorgen die batterien oder die gast gast
kartuschen die da drinnen passiert
er sagt aber wir müssen weg weil die
feuerwehr jährige durchkommen wir müssen
sicherlich krankenwagen klar dass der
fahrer auch heißen darauf liegt in der
luft
hardy erkundigt sich nach dem
verunglückten kollegen
ja auch sagen der fahrer raus ist es ist
also gut mit die ursache kann alles
mögliche sein kabelbrand mit eben mal
motor überhitzt schnell falsche
kabelverlegung sich selber vielleicht
angebaut was eigentlich nicht häufig ist
der kreis passieren
anderthalb stunden braucht die feuerwehr
um den transporter zu löschen wie sich
herausstellt ist der wagen das
begleitfahrzeug eines anderen
schwertransporters die gute nachricht
der fahrer konnte sich retten
ich hoffe bloß dass mir so etwas
passiert solange der fahrer raus ist
alles schick ist
es ist für mich die welt wieder heute in
ordnung
[Musik]
es ist gefährlich geworden auf deutschen
autobahnen seit jahren nimmt der
schwerverkehr zu anstriche grefs fast
täglich die straßen sie zu warenlagern
verkommen
just in time darauf versteht die
industrie und auch der verbraucher die
fahrer stehen unter stress arbeiten bis
zur erschöpfung und werden dabei von
vielen verflucht sie sind die
prügelknaben der autonation einer von
ihnen ist eigentlich schon in rente aber
er kann es nicht lassen
es ist zuhause nina aus erich altmüller
fährt jetzt urlaubsvertretungen
nachfahre laden und soll morgen früh um
8 uhr
es dreht sich doch um die zeit ich habe
meine fahrzeit fast voll in essen
erich gibt alles seine disponenten
wollen mehr nach 44 jahren auf dem bock
wollte er eigentlich seinen lebensabend
mit seiner frau verbringen ganz in ruhe
kaffee trinken muss ich alle selbst
lerne
letzte woche war ja noch zu hause bei
frau ein desaster
mushnik live ist vielleicht für ein ja
und jetzt kann jeder seinem lkw aus
scheibe geputzt keine leichte übung nach
43 jahren wochenend ehe betreibe ach was
doch mit streng er braucht es zwar auch
immer im druck im lkw aber aber nie
unter beobachtung so wie du
das gemeinsame renten leben haben sich
beide anders vorgestellt
erich sehnt sich zurück auf die autobahn
meine gewohnte droht das ist nichts für
mich
[Musik]
ganz unter kontrolle
und sowieso erich fühlt sich viel zu
jung für die rente
ich bin im kopf bin ich noch 50
aber gott sei dank gibt es die
vertretung jobs da hat rentner her ich
alles wieder eine autobahn sein lkw und
den stau in einer früher sein halbes
leben hat er so gestanden auf der
dritten spur fahren auf der dritten spur
nach zwei stunden stillstand reißt
selbst begierig der geduldsfaden er
vergisst die guten vorsätze und die
verkehrsregeln
jetzt frage ich rüber letzter raumfahrt
das mache ich wie die anderen auch
[Musik]
im schritttempo nähert er sich der stau
ursache
radio haben sie einen auffahrunfall
zweier lkw gemeldet
seit stunden wird hier geräumt erich sie
zwar fast täglich solche bilder aber
auch nach jahrzehnten auf der straße
führt er die man noch mit
[Musik]
der noch mal raus gekommen ist hier
wenn er es überlebt hat dann ist eben
irgendwo jetzt im krankenhaus und war
deine leute zu haus stehe die polizei
und muss dann so eine nachricht
überbringen
das beschäftigt schon anderswo in
deutschland
ein autotransporter unterwegs ins
ruhrgebiet
karl jakob macht den job auch schon 20
jahre
allerdings hat der trucker gerade die
firma gewechselt sein lkw neu und
ungewohnt
im moment aber er wird ihn ein voll
besetzten linienbus der auf der dritten
spur an ihm vorbei rast menschen weniger
wert sind wie material der bus der auf
100 fahren wird über 50 leuten an bord
wir haben paletten druck dürfen nur 80
fahren
der darf auf der dritten spur überholen
wir haben über alkoholverbot also vom
prinzip jedermann dann andersrum
überlegt könnte man ja denken der
menschen sehr erschwert oder ist genervt
er muss vor betriebsschluss beim kunden
sein 20 minuten bleiben wenn er zu spät
kommt muss mir vor dem autohaus
übernachten gerade noch geschafft
aber jetzt
[Musik]
nach neun stunden autobahn schlägt er
sich jetzt mit dem ungewohnten aufleger
herum alles anders als früher
kai hat genug
gerade im moment überhaupt killesberg
main
[Musik]
leck mich am arsch nicht
etwas holprig zwar aber rechtzeitig
bringt keil den ersten arbeitstag mit
dem neuen egger dahinter spielen
[Musik]
eine papierfabrik in holland erich der
teilzeit rentner aus der pfalz ist früh
dran wird als erster beladen
er ist topfit es läuft alles wie am
schnürchen
selbst die hitze kann ihm nichts anhaben
andere rentner gehen schwimmbad in die
sauna
ein dutzend rollen papier 2000 kilo
jeder einzelne erich ist verantwortlich
für die ladungssicherung einen
anstrengenden tag nicht nur körper
[Musik]
ein fehler und er bringt sich und andere
in große gefahr
[Musik]
das ist dabei erst der anfang des 15
stündigen arbeitstages
das schlimme ist
ich mache circa 38
grad außentemperatur ladung sicher die
alle graf gefördert
und vor mir liegen jetzt 700 kilometer
nach plattling die sprache
er brauchte konzentration erst mal ein
bisschen durch banken
das gefühl von freiheit genießen wie er
es nennt termin tag eine der härtesten
jobs auf der autor ein
zum glück kennt die richtigen aden losen
zeitplan seiner disponenten noch nicht
wir kommen kurz hinter der grenze
per e mail kollege hardy mit dem
schwertransporter hat es noch
rechtzeitig in den rostocker hafen
geschafft trotz feuer und stau letzten
acht er hat nur kurz geschlafen
sein begleiter rocco und chemischen
jetzt die ladefläche vorbereiten damit
das maschinenhaus einer windkraftanlage
draufpasst wir müssen jetzt nur fünf
meter fünfzig auseinander ziehen
damit war maschinenhaus sehr oft kriegen
ich hätte so landete
sie fahren die achse auseinander
der leichteste teil der übung denn das
geht automatisch dann heißt es wieder
absenken und die tonnen schweren
gusseisernen querstreben in position
bringen und hier passiert es der rücken
hardy hat es seit jahren mit dem kreuz
ja gerade der kreuz verdreht beschissen
bewegt den hebel aufgemacht kreuz
verdreht ist mir schwindelig du aber
schon haltung ist jetzt nicht drin ist
weiß ausbrüche habe ich jetzt den
wahnsinn gar nicht abwarten müssen weg
geht was sag ich mal
ich werde ja eine schmerztablette
schmerztablette mir ein werfen und dann
geht weiter
jeder normale aber nehmen würde wohl zum
arzt er ist nur am wochenende zu hause
allenfalls im urlaub schaut er mal zu
einem check vorbei während der tour gibt
es für hd nur die chemische keule
die räder müssen rollen seit der wie
viele seiner kollegen hat ihr nur eins
im kopf
die fracht muss rechtzeitig ins ziel
[Musik]
doch kaum unterwegs droht das nächste
problem also polizei gefahren sind haben
hab so ein spiegel sehen
brandenburg polizeihauptmeister werner
beinhart auf position auf dem parkplatz
an der a 12 zwischen frankfurt oder und
berlin hat er die lkw im visier
kollege ralf rick ist der video fachmann
in dem als camper gedanken high tech
ausgestattet mit verdeckten kameras
können sie unauffällig gegen
verkehrssünder vorgehen die polizisten
haben gerade wieder einen ausgemacht der
truck aus weißrussland ist viel zu
schnell unterwegs hält kaum abstand 50
meter sind pflicht er hält sich nicht
kilometer 30 und 28 zu dem bereich heiko
verstehen dass gefährliche in dieser
situation ist dass auf diesen
gefahrguttransporter aufgefahren ist der
nach entweder diesel oder benzin geladen
hat auch wenn er nicht voll ist ist er
gefährlich wie weit waren dass nach
stand 12
wenn überhaupt eine chance hat lange ich
anhatte reaktionszeit wenn das
bremspedal zu treten
aber hier ist mein heim die polizistin
andere sorgen
kommt da raus springen jetzt kann da
nicht bei der trucker markt nicht was er
soll das kennen die beamten schon viele
fahrer fürchten einen trick kommen sie
aus noch aus nach gegend wurde das
wahrscheinlich ab und zu mal geschieht
habe dass ich schon bei deutschen lkw
fahrern gehabt die da nicht mithalten
sie gucken zu viel preis und dann kommt
er aber dann doch noch um die ecke und
dann fahren wir heute bahn und dann in
dunklen brandenburg ich im wald haben
ein bisschen angst hat dass er
überfallen wird da kann man bis zum
verständnis erfahren
ja du hast immer misstrauisch willkommen
doch er kommt einer stelle jemand rühmen
mit der schiebetür hierzu der seite der
fahrer versteht können wollte aber für
den fall haben sie ja die wie die
ordnerin das video ist zwar wackelig
aber eindeutig der fahrer versucht sich
trotzdem auszureden der lkw vor ihm sei
schuld der aber abrupt gebremst
[Musik]
das scheint geklärt aber die überprüfung
ist noch lange nicht zu ende
kollege rick macht noch eine weitere
brandgefährliche entdeckung ein
gaskocher auf dem beifahrersitz
hierzulande streng verboten
der fahrer jedoch sieht das alles nicht
einen fühlt sich gegängelt
[Musik]
da war es größer muss strafe zahlen
jetzt gleich und mit 100 euro kommt eher
glimpflich davon
nochmal glück gehabt dem tiefen
brandenburger wald teilzeit rentner
erich arndt derweil das ist ein lade
termin nicht mehr schafft die firma
macht gleich zu zudem kämpft er gegen
das navi er traut den dingern nicht
freunde meter rechts
[Musik]
gespräche in berlin
ich frage mich ja ja
ich fahre hier nicht rein jetzt brechen
die neue hierzu eine spende ich spreche
zum sommer thuner fans wollen kreis
einmal 3 km sie sich irgendwo in der
pampa sich zwar nach details dass man
sagt dass die baustelle
ich krieg die krise
aber wir setzen hier einfach
wir kommen nur aus ja ist auch große
firma oder muss ja irgendwo eine ausgang
sein also hierher die welt und keiner
meter er wird ihr übernachten müssen
das ist das ende ohne toilette und
fließend wasser
das ändern
polizeihauptmeister werner meyn hage ist
immer noch wachsam in ihrem bundesweit
einzigartigen gefährt halten die beiden
beamten ausschau nach verkehrssündern
unter den truckern wieder beginnt die
wilde aufholjagd ein raser der trotz
strikten verbot einen lkw nach dem
anderen überholt elefantenrennen unter
promis den übeltäter einzuholen dürfte
für den polizeiwagen eigentlich kein
problem sein aber dann
neben diesen schritt land
ich hoffe dass ich den krieg
ja da nur dort sieht jetzt doch noch ab
und zu mal da ist so ein elektro teil
der gute stern auf allen straßen versagt
das jetzt gerade machen das ist doch
ausgerechnet jetzt
es ist nicht zum aushalten
eine ganze zeit läuft in ordnung
das ist doch zu machen
vergessen wir nicht aus vorbei straka
ist kurz vor dem ende der
vorgeschriebenen lenk zeit sucht
dringend einen schlafplatz zwei
rastplätze waren randvoll
bis zum nächsten reicht es noch für
einen plausch mit seiner ehefrau so gern
hier jetzt ein gewinn habe im lkw
schlafen
das mache auch durch zu hause bis zum
bekommt der hund mal meine frau sich
jetzt seine katze anschaffen dann kommt
die katze mal
und hier habe ich nicht hier ist meine
ruhe und dann schlafen
aber erstmal einen schlafplatz finden
spätestens gegen 18 uhr sind die park
und rastplätze voll bis auf die
einfädelspur dicht an dicht 20 die lkw
aneinander und ganz vorne steht sogar
eine auf der fahrspur
und kann uns in der 35 hunderttausende
machten die angeschlossen er macht keine
anstalten sich zu fragen wie wird nervös
punkten an
dann endlich fährt er los
die anlage hat gewirkt
schade es wahnsinn es ist wahnsinn was
hier auf parkplätzen loslegen
weiter geht die reise an überfüllten
parkplätzen und raststätten vorbei bis
tief in die nacht hinein
ks total übermüdet seit stunden sucht er
einen schlafplatz von einem kollegen
bekommt er einen tipp der betriebshof
einer firma irgendwo im nirgendwo
neben der autobahn so richtig geheuer
ist ihm der platz nicht aber was bleibt
ihm übrig so vor dem einschlafen
überkommt ihn auf die sehnsucht nach zu
hause vor einem jahr hat er zum zweiten
mal geheiratet seitdem ist er ein
anderer mensch sagt er selbst seine
extreme eifersucht scheint geheilt und
seinen hochzeits film den trägt er immer
bei sich
solchen stimmungen schaut er ihn sich
gerne
ja super schöne wer also waren noch
negativer erinnerung war zu dem
zeitpunkt meine mutter sie lagen im koma
und an dem tacho heirat haben ist
aufgewacht gerade hat man natürlich
immer im hinterkopf waren die ganzen
tränen die augen wie er später
mein schwiegervater wandrey gewesen
obwohl es schwer krank war der
mittlerweile hoch verstorben müssen aber
sowohl danach die feier die freunde
hatte stimmt also wir alle zu bringen
bei so einer großen familie fühlt es
sich auch nie alleine der familie die
auch wieder dabei die jüngste tochter
die müllerstochter meine frau
und diese nachts immer bei mir beim
schlafen müssen sie ja als krieg aber zu
hause ja und welche gleich alles schön
hin positionieren und dann wenn man
zusammen kusche hd mit dem maschinenhaus
auf seinem spiel laster muss bis morgen
früh auf der baustelle in süddeutschland
seien die nachtfahrer sei mit ständigen
lichtreflexen schlaucht er hat druck
kann er den termin nicht halten
verzögert sich der aufbau des winters
eine teure angelegenheit für seinen chef
und immer noch die rückenschmerzen
inzwischen stellen sie über den nacken
biss in den kopf extrem dass der
tablettenkonsum schmerz werde das tempo
extrem zeit- und welche
kopfschmerztabletten teilt oft hast so
phasen da wurde extrem ist oder der
emittent hat ständig kopfschmerzen haben
nur mit chemie oder tabletten in
tablettenform versuchstiere landtag zu
kommen so extrem
noch zwei stunden bis zur baustelle bei
normalen verkehr
doch dann ein lkw fährt rückwärts
[Musik]
straftatbestand ein sattelschlepper hat
die ausfahrt verpasst stößt zurück um
abzubiegen
jetzt hat die ausgerechnet ihn vor sich
doch
[Musik]
mühsam arbeitet sich hardy durch den
kreisverkehr
leider will auch der verwirrte kollege
in seiner richtung stur bleibt der vor
ihm
naja die steigt der blutdruck
der voerder man hält auffährt unnötig
langsam auf den nächtlichen lärm straße
wir kennen die strecke ja sind unter
zeitdruck ist das natürlich der
rückwärts auf der autobahn fährt weil er
sich da keine schilder lesen kann
dann fährt er noch vor dir auf der
landstraße oder sich auskennen und dann
poker da vor uns und wegen so ein
vollpfosten kann es passieren dass wir
enthalt kurz vorm ziel kurz vor der
ladestelle pause und schicht pause
machen müssen
[Musik]
und das würde einen vollen tag verlusten
betreiben deshalb vergisst hardy jetzt
die verkehrsregeln und zieht raus auf
die sehr schmale gegenfahrbahn überholen
mitten in dunklen wald mit seinen drei
meter sechzig breiten und 32 meter
langen monster nichts für schwache
nerven
[Musik]